[Music]
they were just really easy go I'm just
walking in baby and I think that was
real she's Mary Oh 1,000% he has become
more sensible there I say straight off
the plane with two folders held close to
her stomach it was almost like Megan was
giving us a hint this was their first
major overseas tour but as they arrived
in Australia even bigger news was coming
so exciting after months of speculation
Megan and Harry have announced that they
are pregnant five months since they got
married they're expecting their first
baby next spring take you Harry to be my
husband to be my husband with Megan past
the 12-week mark they've told their
families now it was time to share that
news with the world for an excited crowd
outside the Sydney Opera House a
pregnant Duchess and her popular Prince
were too good to miss princess Megan
touched Camilla's hands and will you
remember it for the rest of your life
Harry wanted to introduce his new wife
to an old friend
98 year-old Daphne Dunne who he's met
three times before
like a friendship beautiful and how did
it feel to be able to congratulate them
on soon-to-be pairing it was always to
be expected but the news they're
expecting was going to be at the front
of everyone's mind with gifts from the
governor-general Harry looked more
amused than Megan and was rather coy
delivering his first speech thank you
for the for the incredibly warm welcome
and the chance to meet so many Aussies
from all walks of life and we generate
and we also generally couldn't think of
a better place to announce the upcoming
baby be it a boy or a girl so thank you
very very much the weather wasn't kind
to them but this was an important
working trip dispatched on behalf of the
Queen to show sympathy with the farming
communities who ironically have suffered
from months of drought
Prince Harry seemed in his element when
protocol went out the window
fact that Megan had faked this family a
cake a sign they're doing things
differently yes she made it last night
when she heard she was coming to a
family home that ability to connect is a
very powerful thing when you want to
make sure the monarchy is still relevant
[Music]
on Bondi Beach they kicked off their
shoes to talk about mental health and
couldn't have seemed more at home
we met up with Michele wood from the
Australian Republican movement
she watched their wedding and follows
what Megan wears but thinks the time has
come to ditch the monarchy we're hearing
from all of our supporters which have
grown in number and growing in voice
that the time has come for us to cut the
apron strings if you like and move away
and become an independent country with
an Australian in the top job ahead of
the Invictus games Prince Harry
conquered Sydney Harbour Bridge to fly
his own flag we followed his path to the
top to take it all in a growl Tea House
is where Harry and Megan have been able
to spend some private time in the
spectacular setting of Sydney to really
reflect I think on what this tour means
for them it has been their first major
overseas mission and really it is a
reflection of what their married life is
going to be like together as working
Royals
thank you very much for your patience
everyone and welcome to Fraser Island
tranquil Fraser Island was their next
stop but the Duchess had decided to sit
this one out
bouncing around on a bus you could
understand why we advise early stages
and late stages of pregnancy it's not
advisable but I'm sure just being here
and you know coming over to the island
today it'll being just enough of a
carrot to teaser to come back with an
exhausting itinerary ahead Harry who is
he used to going solo but apparently
told his pregnant wife to pace herself
but when the views look like this you
can see why she didn't want to miss the
walkabout
stepping off the plane in Fiji this felt
like another change of pace almost
20,000 people in the capital Suva to
welcome them with the same ceremony they
gave the Queen and Prince Phillip back
in 1953 it was up to their grandson to
drink the Carver the national drink that
looks like muddy water and isn't to
everyone's taste
[Applause]
their balcony moment was something
straight out of a movie and worth
waiting for in the rain in true South
Pacific style they dressed up for what
was meant to be
Megan's big day her first speech of the
tour about women and education it was
through scholarships financial aid
programs and work-study where my
earnings from a job on campus went
directly towards my tuition that I was
able to attend University and without
question it was worth every effort but
it was all overshadowed when something
went wrong in supers market her visit
cut short her female bodyguard telling
her to leave and lots of confusion about
what exactly had gone on very quick no
good I expected to be little more water
do you see all the handicrafts of the
woman in Fiji it was the first sign that
this is new to her and her team
she has quite an inexperienced team
around her in terms of her aide aside
from her private secretary Samantha
Cohen who is amazingly experienced it
has worked for the Queen in the past and
certainly the police protection offices
the metropolitan police protection
offices have not been looking after her
for that long and I think that they
decided that there were too many people
and they were worried I think perhaps
about her leaving their exits and we
decided to take her out it is obvious
that they've got each other's backs in
Tonga the public displays of affection
that we've seen throughout were
surprised to this more differential
crowd you would you would have to wait
to get spoken to or stuff like that but
here they were just really easygoing
just walking and waving
[Music]
they even got to fit early giggles in
the rainforest at an antique mosquito
song some have been surprised that she
decided to go there because of the Zika
virus
[Music]
Prince Harry may have his own fans but
it's Megan who's really Sean on this
tour and attracted a very loyal
following to me I'm like you're just
this biracial actress feminist and
that's everything that I am everything
that I want
after she loved that's when I broke down
cuz I was just meeting you know your
hero and that's wild so she is your hero
she's Mary Oh 1,000% we sat down with
governor-general Patsy ready
the Queen's representative in New
Zealand she hosted the couple and was
struck by Megan's ability to connect so
much easier to talk about diversity when
you are the embodiment of diversity and
so she is showing that a person of color
a person of mixed race background
heritage can achieve whatever she wants
and that's a great model for New Zealand
the Duchess is starting to show us what
she wants to do with this new royal
platform stepping up to speak at an
event to mark a hundred 25 years since
New Zealand gave women the vote because
yes women's suffrage is about feminism
but feminism is about fairness
suffrage is not simply about the right
to vote but also about what that
represents the basic and fundamental
human right of being able to participate
in the choices for your future and that
of your community a speech that
impressed New Zealand's Prime Minister
Jacinda Arden who had a baby in June and
was back in work six weeks later there
are still things that we need to do
around things like domestic violence and
pay hoodie so having role models from
around the world like yourself standing
up and making statements around just
Venus and equality I think is really
powerful
in the atmospherics setting of rotorua
their final welcome ceremony was the
most powerful prince harry bowing in
appreciation to their Maori hosts the
images have been striking this is a
couple who've done and said all the
right things it was always going to be
fascinating to watch how the couple
coped under the spotlight during this
tour Megan could not be more composed
and Prince Harry has seemed more serious
and statesman like it is how they want
to portray themselves on the world stage
but there are also other important roles
they're now preparing for when they will
become a month and dad next spring the
Royals never like personal matters to
overshadow their official work that has
been impossible on this trip they've
been bombarded with baby gift and
congratulations
they've always been great with children
and now they've got a good reason to put
in the practice their final stop in New
Zealand was a tranquil one only a year
ago they got engaged and you'd think
they'd still be finding their feet this
tour has shown them to be a confident
and impressive royal partnership who
together are now looking forward to life
as a family of three
[Music]
you